[Music]
so we are here on the promo shoot for
season three of um the drew barrymore
show i am so excited because the whole
marketing team saw what i did
at the rock and roll hall of fame
to induct the go-go's because they are
my favorite band in the world and
they're the reason i think that i have
all the courage
and bravery
and
edge i don't know just everything about
me stems from them and discovering their
album when i was a kid we're basically
carrying that over to our season 3 promo
with the go-go's blessing in fact i have
their birthday card right here which
means
everything in the world to me and they
came on the show and surprised me
for my birthday i never would have
dreamt anything like this would ever
actually happen it says happiest of
birthdays to our sister
the six go-go
from the go-go's
the thing about the go-go's that i love
the most is they were really cool fun
girls but they had this great sisterhood
and so when i think of like a charlie's
angels i know that that
is what was the impression to me growing
up that like girls did not compete they
worked together
and
didn't try to pretend to be boys but
could do what boys do
like rock and roll and action and all
that stuff we get to be who we are they
kind of taught me everything we're doing
it till we got the beat which the
go-go's signed off on i mean if that's
not the circle of life nothing is
because i'll never forget when i heard
that drum beat for the first time
it opened a door
and changed my life forever
do you remember where you were when you
heard it i was really young and i was at
a friend's house i don't remember who
the friend was but i remember the room
so well it was obviously the album and
it was on a record player i was really
drawn to the album art it was like one
of these what is this
and
that was when i heard that drum beat
when that needle hit the record and
i've never been the same since i was a
big blondie fan too like debbie harry
couldn't have been any cooler there were
so many amazing girls out there just
letting all of us young girls know that
you were capable of anything and
everything was possible it was really
all about the go-go's for me do you ever
want to be like a rock star type when
you're hearing music like that well i
told steven spielberg funny enough i
told him i was a drummer
[Music]
oh my god what if it's because of that
beat in the go-go's that made me think
drummer
i knew my limitations in music
i knew that i would be the biggest music
fan
but that that was not where my strengths
lie
i really don't sing i don't play but i
know music and i love music and i love
putting music to everything i love
making playlists and i made mixtapes oh
i labored on my mixtape so hard when i
was younger everything had to flow into
the next song and did you ever give
someone a mixtape oh my god yes
especially boys besides
acting though was there ever something
else that you're like oh maybe i could
do that
i always wanted to be a writer i was
always writing scripts for steven
spielberg when i was a kid and getting
his take and approval and
you know just seeing what he thought so
i always wanted to write that was i
think my big goal i'm as happy as i
could ever be in my life because of this
show it is
literally a very positive
environment it's fun and it's sassy and
spirited and humorous and surprisingly
emotional
and it's been the most fulfilling
endeavor i could have ever guessed i
can't believe we get to do a season
three
people are like you have way too much
like eggs in the basket of this show and
i'm like
do you have a problem with that
but i just i love coming here i've also
gone from job to job my whole life
which is such a blessing and i've been
so lucky and i've been given so many
damn opportunities but i love coming to
the same place i love the consistency
i've always wanted like a desk job
in that way of like
you know who you're with you know where
you're going it's so consistent i've
always craved that in my life and once i
had kids i knew i had to find that and i
didn't know where i was going to find it
i did not know i was going to find it
here
i love this job so much is there
anything else you want from this new
season that you're really looking
forward to oh my gosh that's such a good
question
professionally
i think this is an incredible time to
figure out what the new media frontier
is
there is never been a time where we had
this many possibilities and resources
we've got social media we've got digital
i think this is the time where
it's time to unclip wings and reinvent
the wheel personally if i can just
be a little less afraid of this going
away
that would be probably really smart
but
it's like to anyone out there who really
loves something and you just want it to
stay
you know and you don't want to lose it
it's the same feeling that's how i feel
about this
[Music]